Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
Elsa la aplicación puntera de
Inteligencia artificial que te ayuda a
mejorar tu inglés más sobre esto En un
momento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os habéis fijado en estas imágenes pues
puede que te sorprenda pero
perfectamente Podrían haber sido Buenos
Aires en junio del año 1806 la por aquel
entonces capital del virreinato del río
de la plata fue invadida por los
ingleses los cuales al cabo de un par de
meses fueron expulsados al año siguiente
se volvió a presentar exactamente la
misma situación con idéntico resultado
Así que hoy la coña entre algunos
argentinos es que si no hubiera sido por
esa acción heroica de los Criollos
Argentina podría ser actualmente como
Australia por supuesto en realidad no
podemos saber que hubiera ocurrido y
desde luego si algo nos dice la historia
es que el éxito o el fracaso de un país
depende sobre todo de las instituciones
que se hubieran implementado
el caso de Argentina del que tantas
veces hemos hablado aquí en
visualpolitik es buena prueba de ello
hemos hecho un montón de vídeos sobre
Argentina pero lo cierto Es que nos
faltaba un tema clave y es que veréis al
ver el estado en el que se encuentra hoy
este país puede parecernos un Casi casi
una historia marciana de ciencia ficción
pero lo cierto es que un tiempo en el
que la Argentina fue un país muy rico
uno de los países más ricos de todo el
mundo llegó a ser Incluso el más rico de
todos La pregunta es es esto posible
realmente la Argentina fue un lugar tan
rico y tan próspero y de ser así por qué
demonios era tan diferente al país con
el que hoy nos encontramos y una
pregunta también muy importante con la
alergia que los políticos argentinos le
tienen al comercio internacional y al
capital extranjero Qué papel jugaron
Estos factores en esa supuesta era
dorada pues bien veámoslo
Pero antes de continuar no os ha pasado
alguna vez que habéis caído estar
seguros de Cómo se pronuncia una palabra
en inglés y con los años habéis
descubierto que vivíais en una gran
mentira ahora os cuento Por cierto un
ejemplo nuestro real bueno El caso es
que atentos porque Elsa viene el rescate
de todos nosotros la Revolucionaria
Inteligencia artificial de Elsa te ayuda
a corregir tus errores de pronunciación
en inglés mejorando así tu entonación y
fluidez Pero eso no es todo con Elsa
también reforzarás tu vocabulario te
ayudará a tener en tu mente frases del
día a día realmente útiles por ejemplo
la típica conversación del ascensor o la
que ocurre cuando coges un taxi con todo
esto irás mejorando tu dominio del
inglés prácticamente sin darte cuenta
por ejemplo volviendo a lo de las
palabras engañosas sabréis decirme de
dónde era gobernador Bill Clinton antes
de ser presidente de los Estados Unidos
de Arkansas Y cómo pronunciaríais este
estado en inglés Nosotros hemos hecho
una prueba entre buena parte del equipo
y el fallo ha sido generalizado si has
dicho también alcanzas el suspenso de
Elsa también es compartido contigo pero
después de la ayuda del Sara cosa mejoró
algo como podéis ver
más y mejor a tu inglés con la
Inteligencia artificial de Elsa desde ya
tiene es una versión totalmente gratuita
y si quieres ir a por la versión pro con
el link que te dejamos te llevas 7 días
gratis para que lo pruebes y un 85% de
descuento en la suscripción de por vida
o un 40% de descuento en tu plan anual
lo Que prefieras te dejamos todos los
links abajo en la descripción ya lo veis
muy pero que muy interesante
espectacular dicho esto continuamos
el origen de una nación
a finales del siglo XVIII la corona
española decidió crear el virreinato del
río de la plata situando la capital en
la ciudad de Buenos Aires en aquel
tiempo esta región lejana y poco
habitada no era particularmente
interesante para el Imperio español sin
embargo el contrabando inglés y la
expansión portuguesa desde Brasil
hicieron que de repente la coronada se
fijara en este lugar y comenzará a
preocuparse más por él de ahí que
decidieran establecer una presencia más
importante en la región sin embargo el
declive del imperio suma la salud
económica la ocupación de España por las
tropas de Napoleón y la difusión de la
Ilustración hicieron que se
desencadenarán entre los años 1810 y
1825 movimientos independentistas en
todos los territorios americanos del
imperio prácticamente con la única
excepción de Cuba y Puerto Rico de esta
forma entre los territorios separatistas
estaba lo que hoy conocemos como
Argentina y el 25 de mayo de 1810 depuso
al virrey Cisneros para proclamar un
gobierno local digamos que en aquel
momento la excusa formal fue que con el
rey de España encarcelado por Napoleón
Pues el poder tenía que regresar al
pueblo Pues bien Apenas seis años más
tarde el 9 de julio de 1816 la Argentina
su independencia definitiva Aunque lo
cierto es que eso no trajo la paz Los
conflictos y Las Guerras locales se
sucedieron por mucho tiempo y es que en
juego estaba a quienes ocuparía en el
gobierno y qué tipo de gobierno se
establecería fundamentalmente aquí hubo
dos grandes facciones los unitarios y
los federales y es que veréis el
conflicto quedó muy condicionado por el
poder que entonces acumulaba a Buenos
Aires respecto al resto de provincias
como en Buenos Aires se encontraba el
puerto y la aduana que eran las dos
principales fuentes de riqueza este
territorio consideraba que tenía que
tener más derechos que el resto por su
parte las provincias del interior
defendían que nada de nada esos recursos
pertenecían a todos que debían de ser
compartidos a partes iguales y que no
debían existir derechos extraordinarios
Pues bien sea como sea el caso es que el
conflicto se alargó casi 50 años la
disputa solo se terminaría por resolver
A mediados del siglo XIX cuando se
aprobó la Constitución de 1853 y se
federalizó la ciudad de Buenos Aires en
1880 pero sabéis que tras la
proclamación de la independencia la
aprobación de esta Constitución fue algo
así como el segundo momento fundacional
de la Argentina
[Música]
fue a partir de ese momento cuando
realmente comenzó a construirse la
Argentina moderna y cuando empezaron a
ponerse en piel las instituciones que
cambiaron por completo al país y lo
pusieron en dirección a los primeros
puestos del mundo y justo aquí es donde
aparece uno de los nombres claves de
toda la historia Argentina Juan Bautista
alberdi que fue considerado el padre de
la Constitución pese a no ver
participado en la convención
Constituyente sin embargo publicó un
libro titulado bases y puntos de partida
para la organización política de la
República Argentina que fue sin duda
alguna la obra que más influyó con mucha
diferencia en la Constitución
prácticamente ese puede decir que sentó
sus bases Pero por qué os estamos
contando esto en visualpolitik pues
queridos amigos amigas porque en esta
obra alberdi plantea Cuáles eran los
obstáculos a los que se enfrentaba el
país para conseguir el desarrollo
[Música]
Y es que claro como En aquel momento la
Argentina no contaba con metales
preciosos ni grandes poblaciones ni
tampoco estaba cerca del mundo
desarrollado necesitaba un marco
político muy pero que muy competitivo
que le permitirá al país sumarse a la
segunda revolución industrial y en esta
línea Albert detectó cuatro grandes
obstáculos principales que tenían que
superar Sí o sí para dejar atrás la
pobreza y poder despegar la falta de
capital la escasez de población pensad
que en ese momento el país era
prácticamente un lugar deshabitado con
apenas 2 millones de habitantes la falta
de infraestructuras y la falta de
seguridad jurídica sobre todo lo que se
refiere a garantizar la propiedad
privada y la libertad de empresa no sé
casi que podría parecer que hablamos del
siglo XXI pero no lo cierto es que lo
estamos haciendo del siglo XIX ya veis
que muchos de los problemas se repiten
una y otra y otra vez de hecho casi que
podríamos decir que en muchos casos la
Argentina de hoy ha retrocedido casi 200
años atrás en el tiempo nos parece pero
no nos desviemos
[Música]
la cuestión es que todas estas
preocupaciones se recogieron en la
constitución del 53 que dio vía libre la
llegada de inversión extranjera de
inmigrantes que garantizó la propiedad
privada y promovió el desarrollo de las
infraestructuras y así con esta nueva
constitución Durante los tres primeros
presidentes de la Argentina Bartolomé
emite domingo Faustino Sarmiento y
Nicolás avellaneda del país comenzó a
prosperar un proceso que se aceleraría a
partir de 1880 cuando el país quedó
completamente pacificado se integró la
ciudad de Buenos Aires como capital
federal y se incorporó la Patagonia a
partir de ese momento queridos amigos se
puso en marcha el periodo de mayor
crecimiento económico de toda la
historia del país hablamos de un proceso
que se extendió durante algo más de 50
años y que si toda la Argentina entre
los 10 países más ricos y prósperos de
todo el planeta en la primera década del
siglo XX en aquel momento para que os
hagáis una idea es que argentino era el
equivalente al mismísimo sueño americano
[Música]
y así en menos de 4 décadas por ejemplo
el país se convirtió en uno de los
principales productores de alimentos de
todo el mundo con cerca de 12 millones
de hectáreas sembradas 5 millones de
toneladas de granos exportados y
millones de cabezas de ganado Y eso Por
supuesto No es todo el país también
tenía una de las infraestructuras más
modernas del mundo con grandes puertos
tranvías urbanos y más de 28.000
kilómetros de vías de ferrocarril que
recorrían toda la Argentina ahora bien
llegado hasta aquí la pregunta que
tenemos que hacernos es exactamente cómo
cambió la Argentina y qué hizo que su
economía despegara hasta convertirse en
una de las más ricas y prósperas de todo
el planeta podemos acaso encontrar algún
ejemplo concreto de toda esta
prosperidad pues lo cierto Es que
podemos destacar cuatro grandes cambios
que marcaron un antes y un después
atentos porque a continuación vamos a
ver cómo cambio exactamente este país
Este es un ejemplo de lo que se puede
conseguir en relativamente muy poco
tiempo atentos
objetivos soñado
[Aplausos]
[Música]
siguiendo las bases de alberdi y la
constitución del 53 no solo abrió las
puertas a la inmigración sino que la
promovió con la idea de poblar un
gigantesco territorio que estaba
prácticamente desierto de esta forma
entre finales del 19 y principios del 20
llegaron millones y millones de europeos
en busca de una vida mejor para que os
hagáis una idea Argentina era el segundo
destino favorito de los europeos tan
solo por detrás de los mismísimos
Estados Unidos de esta forma desde
inicios del siglo XX la inmigración
estuvo en constante crecimiento
españoles italianos alemanes griegos y
un montón de nacionalidades en 1905 la
población era ya de más de 5 millones
800.000 habitantes y en apenas seis años
creció en un millón más Y a qué vas a la
Argentina Pues a lo que todos a ver si
salgo de pobre diálogo entre el profesor
de derecho político Adolfo posada y un
inmigrante español en 1910 La pregunta
es pero que ofrecía este país pues
además de mucho trabajo había también
salarios mucho muchísimo más alto
por ejemplo gracias a la enorme
prosperidad que se respiraba los
salarios que recibían los inmigrantes
españoles en Argentina triplicaban los
salarios que recibían en España y para
el caso de los italianos se duplicaban
por supuesto No todo era tan maravilloso
el trabajo duro y las protestas sociales
estaban en la orden del día pero claro
con los datos en la mano no puede
resultar extraño que cuando llegaba un
inmigrante pues al poco tiempo convencer
a sus parientes y amigos de hacer las
maletas y mudarse a vivir el sueño
argentino y esto hizo no solo que la
población del país se disparase sino que
además creció mucho más que la población
de países como Canadá o Australia
sorprendidos pues sigamos
[Música]
las arterias de una nueva potencia
otro de los grandes cambios y al mismo
tiempo otro de los factores que
impulsaron la economía gaucha fue el
desarrollo de una moderna red de
ferrocarril Claro en un país tan extenso
y con pocos Ríos navegables El
ferrocarril era una infraestructura
absolutamente clave para poder
transportar mercancías de forma rápida y
barata la buena noticia es que en
aquella época los dirigentes país tenían
esto muy pero que muy claro Así que
pronto comenzaron a construirse miles y
miles de kilómetros de nuevas líneas
entre 1865 y 1910 la red ferroviaria
pasó de menos de 500 kilómetros a más de
30.000 las vías unían Bolivia con Puerto
deseado los Andes con el Atlántico y la
Pampa húmeda con el puerto de Buenos
Aires que es por donde entraban y salía
casi el 80% del comercio internacional
para que os hagáis una idea de 1910 de
Argentina ocupaba Ni más ni menos que el
puesto número 10 a nivel mundial
precisamente por el avance del
ferrocarril y ojo porque en relación a
la superficie la red Argentina era mucho
mayor que la red de Canadá o de
Australia pero aquí tampoco termina todo
sigamos
[Música]
la Ruleta de la prosperidad
otro de los cambios fue la enorme
expansión que experimentó la economía
Argentina vale esto ya lo hemos dicho de
hecho es en cierto modo el tema de este
vídeo pero la cuestión es hasta qué
punto era la Argentina próspera Pues
veréis según las estimaciones dangus
Madison para 1910 solo 7 países en todo
el mundo eran más prósperos Bélgica
Suiza Gran Bretaña y las cuatro
históricas colonias británicas por éxito
económico esto es Canadá Australia
Estados Unidos y Nueva Zelanda incluso
brevemente entre 1895 y 1896 la
Argentina fue considerado como el país
más rico de todo el planeta así que de
esta forma en 1909 no puede
sorprendernos por ejemplo que el ingreso
per cápita argentino fueron 50% más alto
Que el italiano Un 180% superior al de
Japón y Casi cinco veces mayor que el de
su vecino Brasil pero queréis más datos
Y en el mismo año de 1910 Argentina era
la primera exportadora del mundo de
trigo maíz carne vacuna carne ovina y
Lana
entre los años 1900 y 1913 y ojo que
esto es importante las exportaciones
argentinas representaron el 2,1% de
exportaciones mundiales y en 1909
alcanzaron el 2,6%. por comparar en el
mismo periodo Australia tiene una
participación de apenas el 1,5%. menuda
diferencia simple y llanamente en
Argentina volaba el campo hacia de este
país una potencia agrícola las ciudades
no paraban de expandirse y al mismo
tiempo los servicios y la industria
tampoco dejaban de crecer pero un
momento porque aún tenemos que destacar
un último gran cambio que se produjo en
el país
[Música]
el cerebro argentino
en la segunda mitad del siglo XIX
Argentina hizo un enorme esfuerzo en
educación durante esos años se fundaron
cientos de escuelas Incluso se trajeron
profesionales educativos desde los
mismísimos Estados Unidos y no solo eso
en 1882 el presidente Julio roca
promulgó la conocida como ley 1420 de
Educación primaria una ley que instauró
la enseñanza gratuita obligatoria y
laica y ojo porque esto era algo muy
pero que muy poco frecuente en la época
Así que no puedes dañarnos que de
repente las escuelas y los institutos
empezaron a brotar cómo se transporta el
país gracias a ello en tan solo seis
décadas por ejemplo entre 1869 y 1939 y
la analfabetismo se redujo a menos de un
tercio de 70% A menos del 20 y vale
Aunque este dato pueda seguir
pareciéndonos muy alto tenemos que
recordar de que época estamos hablando
por ejemplo si en 1914 en Argentina el
35% de la población no sabía leer ni
escribir en España esa cifra alcanzaba
Ni más ni menos que el 59%.
[Música]
luego además por si fuera poco los
estudios universitarios también se
popularizaron mucho más de lo que era
frecuente en el viejo continente Así que
podemos decir que la Argentina crecía en
producción en población en
infraestructuras y también en formación
y lo hacía mucho más que los países
europeos y que la inmensa mayor parte de
países del Mundo recordáis la coña de la
que hablábamos al principio de este
vídeo sobre La Invasión inglesa de
Buenos Aires pues lo cierto Es que no
hizo ninguna falta a principios del
siglo 20 la Argentina ya era como
Australia incluso la capital Argentina
Buenos Aires era conocida como la París
de Sudamérica sin embargo
desgraciadamente toda esa prosperidad no
duró mucho queridos amigos amigas No fue
un mito ese país existió en Argentina de
éxito fue una realidad
[Música]
el profesor les llevó unos 100 años
primero se independizaron de España en
aquel momento el territorio era muy
pobre luego necesitaron 50 años hasta
promulgar su Constitución y ponerse en
marcha y luego otros 50 años hasta
llegar al momento de su máxima apogeo
entre finales del 19 y principios del 20
Pero por qué se dio todo la vuelta Pues
esa pregunta os la hemos respondido en
un montón de vídeos aquí en visualpolity
podéis encontrarlos todos en una
Playlist dedicada especialmente al país
gaucho que os dejo en la descripción
pero de momento turno para ti crees que
Argentina volverá a brillar algún día
qué piensas que tiene que ocurrir para
que las prosperidad vuelva a este país
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y si este vídeo te resultó interesante
ya sabes No olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a visualpolitik Ah
importante y echale un vistazo a esa
para poder mejorar tu inglés Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]